what is uh in your opinion the best
boston movie because there's some
amazing ones they departed i was in the
town no i'm [ __ ] with the town you're
going to the town over to the party i'm
[ __ ] with the town because slain's in
the town the slain's my flame's the
homie yeah and that [ __ ] was just flavor
like i couldn't the the dude because i
grew up with them type of dudes
like in cambridge just like my
neighborhood was mostly black but then
there's like um
like a part of campus called east
cambridge and it's like those tough type
of white boys and then i went to school
in charlestown where they made that
movie so i grew up with those type of
dudes and jeremy renner when i found out
he was australian my mind was blown
because he killed him because he did
[ __ ] good kid he did great
yeah he did great
he did [ __ ] good kid yeah it's it's
crazy because if you like i actually
know people from boston and then you
watch a movie where they're trying to do
the boston accent
and not everybody has that [ __ ]
i don't have that like you don't have
the heavy uh getting the [ __ ] car get
in the [ __ ] car dude yeah yo
something something about i did good
right there i think you did i mean i
think you can hit it bro
shout out every time i go to boston and
dj bro
and there's like the drunk boston white
chicks i'd just be weak as [ __ ] the way
they be talking
yo can you play some [ __ ] pitbull
play some [ __ ] people dude
uh shout out to boston man